dort wird gesponsert vom toyota auris
hybrid
er braucht keine steckdose und wer
trotzdem elektrisch
[Musik]
mythos wieder brüten teile mit dass ich
ja aber das ist ja nicht gerade zur
geschichte erzählt lächeln das ich
schweizer marcel sind von großer
bedeutung für das land machte gemüter
oder historische fakten in einem jahr
über schweizer geschichte gestritten
wird wie schon lange bei mir wissen was
ich war dann beim erklärt hemmschuh
und warum ist er so wichtig weil ihr
inneres risch zukunft
[Musik]
eine klasse und vorab burgert ganz genau
erkannt wurde
macht wurde die sender der schlacht der
haupt bürger von der eidgenossen
wir stehen da vor dem rathaus in schwyz
oder recht vor sondern ganz viele bilder
darauf welle tv
bis mitte schlacht am morgarten schlacht
am morgarten während generationen
sinnbild für freiheit und unabhängigkeit
fortschritts sagte klotz als vorstand
der vsg network lösung kurz auf dann
wird die spitze vor sie hier das große
reise überfallen sind sie damals in
einem wirklich gut sie wurden ja das
könnte mir durchaus auch so betrachten
die geschichte erzählt vor die auswahl
bio ja natürlich aber ich bisher
geschichte interessiert ich tu dir
inhalt jahre wieder aus dem grund weil
ich sie als kind so verzauberte schule
im unterricht als historiker sage coach
des freiheits schlacht sie statt
das stört mich nicht das ist schöner
oder geschickt man darf sich darüber
streiten wie viele das darf auf
fragwürdige oder aber das ist ein
konflikt klarheit ich glaube das ist das
ist ziemlich
im 19 jahrhundert machte druck als wirst
sie mit letzte detail zu der schlacht
lang haben sich die geschichte erzählt
dort überschütteten sie den feind mit
einer wahren lawine von felsblöcken und
baumstämmen zu 650 jahren viel verrät
genossenschaft mit zweitem auftritt
hätte man morgarten inszeniert für die
geistige landesverteidigung
die österreicher flogen japaner
verschwand unter den füßen der berger
und sie dankten gott für ihre rettung
für ihren ruhm wollen weg von morgen ist
es das was sie der schuh zu magath
erklärt haben berliner truppe genoss uri
schwyz und unterwalden smart ergebnis
her für habsburger kampf helm der haft
genommen und ihre freiheit verteidigen
besonders schweiz das geschichtsbild vor
generationen historiker roland dann war
und gedankenlos das automodell wieder
heftige debatten aus interessiert an
politik ist oracle die nummer der
schweiz sind und schrieben sie findet ja
kein bewies dass die segel setzen die
gelbe seiten das also keines nehmen sie
auch enorme zunahme war das behauptete
sich gehen und die stimme trainieren sie
verständlich
schweiz und deutschland zielen für
national konservative historiker
nestbeschmutzer und geschichte vom land
benötige
thomas maissen hält e10 getankt und war
mit dem neuen buch politisch lacht
erfassen wo viel zur schweizer
geschichte publiziert hat drive in der
bundeshauptstadt
wenn es möglichkeiten
alleingang oder die bilaterale oder ein
eu-beitritt da sind vielleicht die
möglichkeit wahr material sind dann muss
man doch die drei möglichkeiten offen
diskutieren und was die svp will ich
dass ich seit mai mit diskutieren das
andere gar nicht es gibt kein anderer
weg als der alleingang will mir schon
immer live sie sind und wenn wir unsere
unseren wohlstand unserer feder und
unsere demokratische ordnung nur beim
alleingang verdanken das stimmt - auch
historisch nicht und wenn man das
historische zeigen das nicht stimmt
eröffnet das die politische geschichte
schlachter fokussieren
man wird nicht entsorgt ruhm
interessiert dort lockt nicht auf die
institution aber das land stark macht
kann man noch nicht als kulturgeschichte
durch die durch frauengeschichten wenn
sie dass man vergisst die wirtschaftlich
günstig dass highstreet in ihrer ganzen
vielfalt ganz ganz ganz wenige man
trainieren und will mit einer element
wenn man stark machen wenn man zukunft
machen
das funktioniert kann man muss doch um
zu wissen wo man muss man die ganze
breite ist das ganze historische
potenzial im anker und das papier vor
augen zu führen
[Musik]
zum morgen das ist historiker hat ein
zwischen schweiz und habsburg 315
konflikt gar hintergrund und
detailwissen haben hunger bis feststeht
hoetmar schwer schwyz uri und
unterwalden sich im ernstfall gaga sie
quarz helfer des seglers in bunte blumen
kanton schwyz gar nichts andere monats
und die verbindung zu der am ort
geschlachtet
der patch liegt hinter der maschine
bildungsseminaren versteckter große
geschichte das ist dass sie das und hat
aktuell 16 taxonomische großvater migros
von tadaa mit dem general guisan
abbildet dass ein team mit einer starken
und mir die welt erzählt dass eigentlich
der großvater die heutige gedanke wir
wollen am 15 november in sattel ist dass
der auf ihn zurück arriva das eigentlich
auch stuttgarter jubiläumsjahr hätte
bert schnüriger wundert nur dass
aktenkundig politisch vor dem wurde
großvater denn im zweiten weltkrieg
hier war die trickser sagte ruff bewahrt
und in der regierung sagte clinton dem
briefwechsel zwischen dem
organisationskomitee und der jährige auf
und kommt und die deckschicht camp dass
diese feige die fundstelle für gleiche
geschichte kein k das ist mir auch sie
ihr auto dokument zeiger vom schweizer
regier die kette großvater schwierigen
für das vorhaben kreon stöckige pro
darum hätte sarah packt hätte schweizer
regierung eine illustre gästeliste
präsentiert wir vom ok also für ein
großvater heinz gebe es freut uns ihnen
mitteilen zu können dass die regierung
vom zog der herr general herr bundesrat
unter der hochwertige herrscht abt von
einsiedeln
der kommandant des vierten alkohol und
zu bieten als die verstaatlichte hre
zugesagt haben sie sich jung zu sagen
[Musik]
schweizer regierung ist doch schließlich
aus aufmarschiert wurde im ramona mack
hat die fotos der großvater schneidige
haben generell die finde keine worte um
meinen gefühlen ausdruck zu verleihen
die mich bei dieser erhabenen sein
die initiative vom großvater schnüriger
früchte trägt
die vertreter der landesregierung
bezeugen durch ihre anwesenheit das ohne
die tapferkeit und die weitsicht der
männer am morgarten die
eidgenossenschaft als ganzes nicht hätte
entstehen können
gründungsmythen war der zum festen
bestandteil von geistige
landesverteidigung was bis dato
konfessionsübergreifend frieden
gestiftet hat gilt bis heute als optics
modell für mögliche betrüger
und dort ist sehr sinnvoll sie das
wetter und wir sind schon immer bereich
sie uns verteidiger für unsere freiheit
wir sind in der demokratischen tradition
was alles stimmt man das einfach live
betrieb und die situation ist heute ein
anderes übertrieb dass man sage was ich
tatsächlich in unserer vergangenheit
freiheitlich und wo ich unsere
vergangenheit und freiheitliche
schweizer mühte sich im zentrum vom
nationalmuseum und zürich und im
mittelpunkt von der aktuellen
geschichtsdebatte in bau und gedenkjahr
was ist mythos was ist wahre geschichte
war historisch korrekte oder die
mythisch verklärte dass mieter auch
wichtig sind glaube ich schon aber man
kann doch nicht der grund lag sie für
politik gestaltet das würde sie doch aus
jurist alexander man juristisch gemüter
zum gesetz machen wird zitieren da
unverdächtig ricarda ob sie geschehen
also die daten
ob sie geschehen ist hier nicht zu
fragen
die perle jeder sage ist ihr sinn
und das stimmt wenn ich meinen enkeln
bestzeit linie ich meine stelle
schweizer schiff musiklehrer ist der
rücklauf blüte ganz wichtig zu nehmen
übrigen
[Musik]
was liegt der neue blick wenig schicht
sommer der schule in höhe von ca
muss jetzt natürlich vorstellen dass sie
nicht alles habsburg gelang sie und
opern auf die figur als immer in der
schweiz und der lektor stoßen aneinander
notorischen ist dahin
[Musik]
die geistige landesverteidigung wird der
heldenmythos mit dem land am stauffacher
geschickt inszeniert jetzt wirklich
vorstellen die mit einer russin und
plötzlich kam von links und rechts flüge
und hinterteile nach spitze nach einer
mit waffen auf die hauptgewinne träumt
also da muss ganz fechtkampf wurde sie
ihren vortrag von einer historisch
gehört schweiz vortag und die
geschichten erzählt der alte dokument
und der natürlich zeigt drücken sie in
die seele geschrieben und wir längere
sicht ein zukunftsforum erwartet als
politik im quarz aubert quandt verzählt
das muss sie anschaulich durch die wagen
jedoch dass man jenen der studie können
nicht jedes detail ist klar es ist ja
gar nicht klarkommen minimum reduziert
werden
seit der schlacht stattgefunden das im
november 17.15 das ist der unterschied
das ist doch mal ist sie aber was genau
ist weiß man nicht also finde ich
einfach kritischer als die vorherigen
die ermittler arbeitsblätter wo man das
jetzt einfach wird es für bare münze
verkauft hat möchte ich das ruhig so
thematisieren wirtschaftlich wie werden
meine aber ich bin auch ich schließe
mich immer schwieriger die und sage dass
das wichtig wie drinnen
gute geschichte wo danken auch werde ich
das muss ich so verzerrt und gehört zu
der region
[Musik]
der höhepunkt vom gedenkjahre margarita
die wahrheit hat niemand gedacht
ich bin keine gerne
ich liebe mythen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das ist weder eine bestätigung aus mir
dauerte zusammenhalt aber die schweiz
hätte mehr zusammen
und das bedeutet einfach das ist für
mich die harte schnitte mehr
patriotismus oder weiße politisch
volksfest
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich find's gut dass man das tier das man
weiß woher das man könne das alte lied
vorsingen ausland training konnten und
so dass mit einer anzeige für äußeres
[Musik]
kriegt nur nicht genau weiß dass
gegangen ist liegt das wenige das da
würde ich aber ein gesichertes zu das
ist da am morgarten schlacht gehabt das
bewiesen nun mal gerade mal zwei objekt
im bundesbrief museums schweiz die
erfahrene da hier stehen vor der
schweizer als schlacht mit dreht wurde
wasserrohr gott aber genau abgespielt
hat über das für die schlacht wird der
blumige worte erzählt und diese gute
geschichte was machen sie damit
das ist ausgezeichnet die geschichte
mich zählen nur sagen mir dass es
bittere geschichte nicht um historische
tatsachen handelt sondern um ein mythos
die schlacht am morgarten hielt im 14
jahrhundert auf die weiterentwicklung
von schweizer vertreibt genossenschaft
aber nachdem sie im 16 jahrhundert und
den vor allem im neunzehnten
jahrhunderts zur ersten großen freiheits
schlacht vor der alt genossen gemacht
worden ist geht es hier sehr große
symbolische bedeutung
die starken und positiven einfluss auf
die nationale identität dem land
[Musik]
die minimal sagt ist sagte berrys stück
kurz nach der schlacht eu die schweiz
und wunderbar das bündnis gemacht ob es
an die familie jahrhundert ausgründung
von eidgenossenschaft gute
er stellte bunds gründungsdatum
zurückdatiert auf die rourke und da hier
der bund von 1201 zählt ist irland
friedensbündnis was noch geht
uri schwyz und unterwalden
gründungsmitglied genossenschaft so hält
es schon wenn sie sehr getrübt wurde sie
vom rötlich sie haben völlig recht ich
mir ab ließ die rennanzüge wusste ich
doch
[Musik]
helene schweitzer gründungsmythos
vater und sohn karma sieht eine
geschichte verbunden
rp traurig historiker und politiker als
journalist wird waldwochen ist
verantwortlich für ein sonderheft zu
schlachten
das besucher zum die schweizer
geschichte und ihre die offenheit der
große druck ist also zwei kopien also
sowie die annexion informiert
die burgen schule sind immer nur in die
schweiz fehler gemacht und wir sind
grundsätzlich irgendwo sie muss
schlüssigkeit und wirklich auch immer
vor der schweiz und natürlich und das
haben wir jetzt noch ein foto gemacht
das ist eine schlacht die schlacht
geschichte wurde tatsächlich vor ihm
das ist es so dass ich gut in 30 euro
muss was wir haben gegen die
mittelschicht geschafft sich geschichten
und ich habe nicht so dass mich jetzt
nur die schlacht gewinnt
das ist aber in serie womit machen will
man vernachlässigen müssen immer
verzählt mit dem bhu freiheits
schlachter verknüpftes geschichtsbild
genossenschaft sie geben sie machen vor
ort konnten standen
zum bund server in rom nach din a5 vita
die orte tour motto freiheit steckt was
sie tat genossenschaft schnappte freies
land vor der habsburgische tyrannen
[Musik]
die aktuelle forschung verwirft die
thesen und beschreibt für zitate und
1400 es verwirrend schlacht vom bündnis
und mit roter allianzen mit hopps
stadland silan immer labiler gleicht
wird forschungsmittel vom 15
jahrhundert kunden vor der
eidgenossenschaft reden und tier blieb
nur vom heilige römische reich deutscher
nation
was wenn das geschichtsbild braucht für
die heutige zeit eine schnee wird uwe
podium darüber steht das was ich ihnen
vor wölfe ist ja nicht aber sie machen
dieses ziel sie sich reden dieses
neunzehnte jahrhundert schlechten das
müssen sie mir bei meisten belegen das
können sie aber als historiker wo sie
sagen hier machte er meisten das
neunzehnte jahrhundert schlecht ich
mache ihnen einen vorwurf herr keller
und ihren partei angehören dass sie
diese geschichten des 19 jahrhunderts so
weitere zellen also bis 20 sind nicht
gegeben hätte sie machen uns immer zum
vorwurf da wir hätten jetzt die die
geschichte instrumentalisiert aber
letztlich ist das so ein garten den man
sich selber überlassen hat die svp hat
sich diesen garten angenommen und siehe
da der eine oder andere richtet sich
dort ein und trainiert seine selber land
jetzt kommen plötzlich ansage
nationalkonservativen haben jetzt da
diese diese diese geschichte okkupiert
und und und instrumentalisiert dass ich
- es sich um die um die schweizer
geschichte und sie tun es und sie tun es
heute abend alle die debatte fahrer mit
der bi ist sicher als pacman retten und
historiker rebecca will ich sitze nicht
von ihrem lagerfeuer das kann ich ihnen
sagen wo ich nicht zufällig irgendwo
eine wurst zu braten aber an wiesen und
historischen lagerfeuer sitze ich nicht
und das wird ja auch den linken immer
vorgeworfen von heißt warum wir dass wir
bauern sind leiden werden dass wir
schweizer bayern und wir würden nur
deshalb in die eu das wäre ja dann keine
schweizerinnen und schweizer mehr sind
da muss sich einfach sagen dass es nicht
so und es gibt eben auch nicht nur
einfach eine schweizer geschichte
in kontrast zu der schlachter was
patricks an die vorsitzende anke und
macht das im ganzen land friedenslinde
gesetzt werden
rot grünen
[Musik]
die glocken haben am dienstagabend den
frieden verkündet die worte unsere
bundesräte die vom radio über das ganze
abendliche land getragen wurden malen
uns am werk des jungen friedens mit
dankbaren reifer mitzubauen wir werden
diese worte in die neue zeit des heilens
und aufbauend mitnehmen
am 11 morgenland kelly brook gebrütet
und bezieht wird sich immer wieder von
neuem für wäsche und lückenhaft liebe
und gerade darum haben wir uns
entschieden die friedenslinde pflanze
und mit der gedanke daran erinnere dass
kraft für die menschen nicht nur für
nichtig und zerstöre ich auf ihre
sondern genau zufrieden
der index liegt an die jetzt aspekte in
rebecca wird über zwischen thalfang rom
zu machen
die isolierte anderen staaten auf und
analytics ist er also für euch ist ohne
gedanken als wichtige wetter die
geschichtlichen ereignisse sprechen
ich wollte nicht gegangen die alle tagen
und ich danke frau süd ist noch
wichtiger was im 20 jahrhundert passiert
ist dort immer ganz im westen gebraucht
[Gelächter]
wenig spannend aber die hornhaut den
abend findet das mixed blick in den raum
ob das ist nach null grad etwas hinter
student die passat ist ein anderer staat
sie wenn überhaupt keinen unterricht und
in auschwitz befreit
[Musik]
beck regiert seit start gesehen der
ehemalige dienst kamera der gedanke
einen verstorbenen kollegen
[Musik]
selbstverständlich ist die neutralität
1515 nicht einfach vom himmel
aber norbert robers aber tatsache ist
dass schweizer damals sitz gefunden ja
selber die ihrem namen gleich irgendwie
wirkt führte
wenn alle anderen länder in europa
auswählen der gründer immer sichtlich
verhalten hat mit schweiz kann ich jetzt
führt hatte er war den kontinent einiges
leid der sport liebe und die müssten
jetzt denn im nichts fix an die von 1945
begann
[Musik]
beim apéro am gottesdienst juni 2000
konto nicht weiter wo politisch nicht
auf der bühne heimatgeschichte vom land
für die viel bedeutet na ja also ich
sage immer ich bin stolz auf die
geschichte wo zu mir gehört aber ich bin
immer wieder gefordert was bedeutet die
geschichte hat sie machen mich eher
nachdenklich wenn ich mich immer wieder
frage warum brauche ich den audi gesicht
für genau das wieder im moment und
spannende nicht fragen was will ich
eigentlich was eigentlich für das ziel
mit dem engagement
ich denke in jedem sind sie nicht
sonnenstaat wo werden die demokratische
ohne gummi eingriffs volk prozent sie
definieren da bin ich ehrlich gesagt
immer wieder fest dass da was ich schon
mit dir die unbedingt die letzte frau
beim abarbeiten ins team hatte der
kartbahn für europa gewertet mit der yoc
ag hat nach der vorstellung setzte ich
mich plötzlich ein politischer
diskussion
also ich sage es mal so wir dürfen diese
wahl unverantwortlich und drücken mir
hängt in die ganze welt
und dazu gehört auch das nachdenken über
verantwortliche innerhalb europa ich
habe ja das mache ich dir und mir sind
da wieder mal melodik 1000 dazu will das
gar nicht so wichtig sei die stimmung
ist nicht wählt oder also wie hätte es
anders mal natürlich
bevor beschränkt ist und ob sie für den
transfer bevor der schweizer sicht wird
irgendwie engagiert das möchten wir die
verschiedensten formen 6 das mini
programm
wir sind dass eine kollision
kohäsionsfonds dass man den erdball
die 24 milliarden mehr stört die
restliche europa mit dem untergang von
minister stöger wenn das kapital welches
nicht
[Musik]
ich habe den mut finden wir doch nur
wenn die freigabe der eu hänge schon
gehofft dass nichts von clean up
schottisch oder öffnung eigenständigkeit
oder passiv weil sich die zukunft und
freiheit auf der strecke demente oder
andere
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sind zwar hier auf der autoshow am
himmel was tun wenn im tal aber haben
wir auch im kanton nidwalden mariä
himmelfahrt groß reken hätte direkter
bezug zu einem jahr
[Musik]
es ist auch schön wieder eine feine
sache
[Musik]
kommt sie da schafft es drinnen schweiz
sie denn 15 15
was ist dran am mythos von mariano ihre
gigantische schlacht verliert
artgenossen franzose sieg schlossen
großmachtpolitik und sie hätten
beschlossen
trotz blieb so hemmschuh marinello ist
wird sie dass man großmachtpolitik ruft
also das ist ja groß macht sie unter
politische bündnis gemacht defensiv und
nationalisten dort neutralität
neutralität doch auch in halle
im gegensatz zur schlacht am morgarten
quartier von mariano in der historische
körper gut gelegen
dätgen ost später 15 15 ganz vorne mit
im kampf und wirtschaftsmetropole
mailand einige sehr starke harte hand
gegen übermächtige französischen könig
aber sie stoßen die grenze
[Musik]
der politische ziel gläubig und
expansionspolitik formuliert ist in drei
genossenschaft mit ihren ganz
unterschiedlichen herrschafts zentrum
unterschiedliche ziele möglich sei die
eine hand wähler in nach links die
anhänger nach rechts 13 hier gemeinsame
strategie wie das zum beispiel
frankreich und um eine königin können
entwickeln
[Musik]
die debatte oder sie machtlos schwarz
schutz vor der franzose verhindern
die venezianische ritter
als gigantisches blutbad unglaublich
viele tote auf beiden seiten
[Musik]
am rand vom ehemaligen schlachtfeld 32
mitglieder von pro mariano komitee sie
können sehr große militär und hätte
letzten schuljahres parat gemacht für
die große 500 jahre dank 44
für 1400 kilometer straße das hätte
jetzt frisch gemacht
huberty mit salon in der agglomeration
von mailand hat das pro mariano komitee
schon vor 50 jahren agiert und da jetzt
kommt der festball musik- und mariano
englisch mit neutralität verknüpft
und den hat man die tafel entwurf steht
der ex noch vom schweizer schlachtopfer
jahrelang hat das diskussionsstoff
geliefert dass eben nicht alles rund und
mädels jetzt aus wahnsinnig lief und
rachtig heute seine kritik von ich sage
mir leid dass wechsel trainiert die sind
unter denkmalschutz
das ist so weil ich noch immer dahinter
jährige opfer vor der schlacht die
werden wach trotz der unzähligen toten
sollten rund um verlust von lombard
genutzter helfer deren niederlage
profitiert im friedensvertrag 100 der
französische könig und gaga mit haut und
ente sich reporter so verschaffen sagt
franzose nach wie vor zugang
also soll dort aber iris lemmer lohans
bündnisvertrag wo immer auch wirtschafts
vertrags sie sind nett und jetzt nennen
sich das auf einmal neutralität wurzel
wurde neutralität der viel wurzeln aber
eine moderne wohnzimmer ist mit der
wende von mariano zu wenden wenn sie
sage neutralität wurzeln denn nicht aus
der bootsfahrt mit dem baum katar bandic
hat das ist ja das problem reformation
ist der entscheidende bruch und in der
reformation geht ein protestantischer
block hinter nike gesellschaft und
katholischer block und dort wird
praktisch unmöglich dass die beiden sich
könnten einige rufen gemeinsam user
politik und 50 jahre head pro mariano
komitee auf italienischem boden
dank mal richtet der niederlage weg will
sie das gamer sachse die idee der
organisatoren die interpretation sowieso
blöd dass man ist und wie schnell das
gab bis 2 mit aller kraft halten
ich wollte sehen ob die frauen ohne
mariano werde swatch in der szene bis
heute sind so wusste also es ist
wesentlich dass ich wirklich wesentlich
im vorgarten von kirche von emmanuelle
steht das mahnmal wort neutralität
gestellt messlatte ganz europa kämpfte
hier in san giuliano milanese mariano
und sido
es ist eine gute gelegenheit um
nachzudenken was europa bedeutet was
frieden bedeutet
christie periode ist dieses thema ist
aktueller denn je
es soll uns daran erinnern was frieden
für europa und für die welt bedeutet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
wir können die vergangenheit nicht für
zwecke der gegenwart zurechtbiegen
ansonsten ziehen wir die falschen
schlüsse für die zukunft
das gilt für den einzelnen und genauso
wird es für eine gemeinschaft oder eine
nation hüten wir uns deshalb vor
voreiligen schlüssen wenn wir in die
vergangenheit blicken bundespräsidenten
persönlich da ist natürlich große um sie
dem land nach vorn wir heute wo es
brennt
das sind sehr wichtige jubiläen die
müssen wir uns gesagt dass da sie so
wichtig ich glaube die bereits über 50
teilnehmen dass der bundespräsident
verwurzelte sie einfach wichtig für das
land würde auch zu überlegen was sie mir
so wurde wenn er heute sind was macht
eigentlich schweizers und da gibt es
natürlich meile steigung wo viel
wichtiger sind als normale steigt zum
beispiel gründe vom bundesstaat 88
denn täglich verfolgt 1891 us markt
schweiz ohne sozialwerk dass sie
meilenstein und diese nicht auf dem
schlachtfeld entstanden
aber kraft hat man natürlich an dafür
aber politisch mit abstimmungen stehen
sachen auf dem schlachtfeld von mariana
ist sitzen neutralität nicht einfach so
entstanden
definitiv besiegelt worden ist sie aber
vor 200 jahren am weltkongress
[Musik]
europa und schweizer neu delhi torriani
hier in wien tagte der bisher größte
friedenskongressen aller zeiten
1815 am wiener kongress für ordner
österreich großbritannien russland und
frankreich dreht genossenschaft nach
langen verhandlungen als gültig die
immerwährende neutralität
die friedliche einigung bedeutet
altersgenosse gebiert im süden verlierer
[Musik]
sie bekommen aber neu ganz neue board
und zwar ist
der schweiz wird unversität die eine
neue grenze garantiert
[Musik]
mit dem historiker und autor hermann
thoma ka-news spuren wie vor alles
geschichte ja ja ja es ist mächtig warum
findet der herr am thema schiffsform
wahlliste wissentlich der hut hoch weil
ich finde hier viel gold erinnert sitzt
sprach grenze zwischen oberen teil ist
also da quasi wirklich die wahrheit ist
wir sind jetzt rufen haben es ja wer
sich also mit stoff nachricht dass euch
historisch bin ich hier der platz
wichtig will 1718 ins knien ins die
kampfkuh franzose wollte rentiert die
barnaby grauholz und hier in der stadt
fulda und hier in denkt oberwallis der
ihrer kampf gegen die franzosen
mittlerweile serviert und verloren und
dadurch enthält 100 dollar gewährt
befreit wurde
oder die ganze genossenschaft ich ja
nicht immer so hat mit alle umgangen die
und untertan gebiet kaum
ja genau und so war das herz und alles
als unter dann gewählt kann und der
alt-bundesrat gespeichert also immer
wieder betont es gibt viel macht und die
oberklasse und ich hatte viel passieren
dann soll ein unter dornen reflex im
stammhirn ist das so in das war
verankern sagt oh je die bürger da und
wir über alles reden da sich beleidigt
wenn wir nicht das holz die herner
behandelt war aber doch eigentlich sind
die historisch ich hab ich immer
passieren dass auf ihn stofflich vario
und der kantone nein lateinischen spruch
man jetzt gar nicht ganz es geht darum
das modell wachsam sie und ich
ich kenne eigentlich ist
trotz der schwierigen steaks geschichte
als 4 200 jahr betritt zur
eidgenossenschaft
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
historie sondern eine legende ein großer
tag für die schweiz 18 52 da geht es
nicht um fakten und das stimmt sollte
sich sicher die genannt wurden ins
oberwallis variable zurück zum ansgar
esch sonderrolle ist und dass ich habe
die lieder schon diskussionsforum ist es
wichtig zu wissen wir haben das immer
sehr wichtig dass die komme ich wohin
gehe ich
das sind die ganz große philosophische
fragen von mensch und das entwurzelt und
hinter beraten zunahm und globalisierte
welt zum dorf wird für man sich fremd
und der pflichten auch nach soja nach
dauerregen
ich frage zurück
kennst du land unterbinden
meine wiege stand
mx
die firma
ich war nie begangen haben wir die grund
von rational ist sie werden sie alle
zählen kantons mitglied des wallis und
der westschweiz schweizer versperrt für
die schweiz wohnsitz leben werden wir so
unbedingt unabhängiges land bliebe und
per briefträger und sobald das die
unabhängigkeit verschwindet gibt es
natürlich der ganze die wäsche sich
kulturen sehr stolz und führungskräfte
das gab der möglichen ließ
europa ist wir werden aber wird die
gebäudehülle
das ist für mich sind das
freundschaftliche beziehung so gesehen
nicht das respektvolle beziehung
wirtschaftlich interessierte aber lieber
politisch unabhängiges land wir brennen
die frage nach dem verhalten ist
zwischen oper und im unterwallis sondern
dir nach der beziehung zwischen schutz
und wirtschaftliche fragen
es geht nicht um mir sehr weh jetzt
irgendwer vergrössern lebt ist aber
jetzt manche nacht voll und ganz
akzeptiert das sind die frauen des
terrors wirtschaftslage werde die
brüchigkeit keinen sichtbar machen und
staatsgebilde sind vielfältig aktiv
[Musik]
tag nach der identität ich für der waage
zukunft grundlegend die eisschicht raum
orientieren kann
kurz würste drum wellig schichten wir
und warum
[Musik]
dog mit toyota auris hybrid
er braucht keine steckdose und fährt
trotzdem elektrisch